i feel like yeah probably maybe
somebody's gonna be worried that i might
write a song about them but also like
before abc or anybody like anybody i was
with that
was a songwriter even wasn't a
songwriter like they would still have
that same worry and i'm like just don't
pick me up exactly just don't cross her
abcd
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all i mean it must feel so good
to be you right now because abcdefu
is literally everywhere i mean do you
still kind of trip out when you hear it
on the radio when you see it in a
tick-tock
i mean it feels like i'm waiting for
somebody to just be like it's a prank
no like like my mom's secretly a
millionaire and she's just been paying
everybody off like
like that's what i'm that's what i'm
expecting for somebody to be like hey
your mom stopped paying me so you're
taking it off spotify nobody likes you
no you're like yeah yeah it makes sense
i get it yeah people are falling in love
with you i mean it's so amazing to have
this debut single resonate with so many
people i mean the song already has over
500 million streams um it's the number
one song on the billboard global 200
chart how does it feel knowing that it's
made this kind of impact so far
i mean
the biggest thing with abc is i always
just wanted to give an open space for
people to be angry and like process
their emotions because like for me
i didn't know that if i like
like there's times where i had
opportunities to be angry and
specifically like towards one person
like who abc was about and i just
thought if i like glazed over it i
wouldn't feel it like i didn't know that
i still like held on to it and i was
gonna need to feel it at some point to
be done with it and like i didn't know
that
and so there's so many like little
events where i didn't feel my anger i
didn't feel my frustration so all of the
little things just built up to this like
big
feeling of just being angry and bitter
and um
if i could have had that type of song or
that open space of just like allowing
myself to be angry or even just to have
permission of just being like hey
you can like hold somebody accountable
for their actions and be mad at them and
still like not be a terrible person at
the same time
so here's my question now that now that
abcdefu is like this smash hit and now
that you got your emotions out and now
that you're kind of like reeling from
the success i want to know has the
person that you wrote the song about
reached out to you have you heard from
him
no the thing is okay okay i released a
song in august and i blocked him on
everything on everything right
yeah i did instagram snapchat his
private account his like public account
on tick tock like all of the things i
blocked him what do you think your ex
would say right now to you um i'm a
psychotic ex-girlfriend crazy person who
writes terrible music no
oh for sure if we were i could never do
anything right when we were dating
definitely not now wow well no you're
doing everything right now you're doing
everything right now and the first step
to that was getting rid of him just by
you know and then get your emotions out
in this song like i said it's gonna be
something that people can resonate with
when they're going through a breakup and
i feel like that's like the power of
music you know bringing us all together
in a shared experience
[Music]
i want to talk about your new single
you're just worthy right yes
[Music]
talk to me about this new song and also
the inspiration behind this one yeah so
it was one of those things where i was
friends with somebody for a really long
time
and there's a night where we crossed the
line
and
after that
i started catching him in lies and it
was very like subtle things he also like
he just wasn't as nice to me he was
saying things that he wouldn't have said
before he was being snarky to me and
like i realized that
all of the things that he did that made
me feel comfortable enough to do what i
did with him it was literally just an
act to get into my pants
and like
once he got what he wanted i was less
interesting to him like i
felt so
used and i felt like
a trophy
that he got and he claimed it and then
there it is i got it and i can just put
it on the shelf now a notch on the belt
is what they call that uh he cheated you
like a notch on the belt and now he's
the subject of your next song i mean
it's brilliant
i mean you have said that you wanted to
create a more accepting culture but also
you want to create more space for your
own feelings in your music is that what
we can expect from your ep coming up
for sure i mean
even for songs like abc and you're
dishonest to exist i have to love the
person very much to get that angry at
them
and
the concept of even just emotions and
one emotion leading to into another is
really exciting to me like even with
your dismorning like i was really sad i
was so sad and then i got really angry
my sadness led into my anger you know um
and i'm really just excited to talk
about how me loving somebody so
extremely
can lead to type of abc song because i
find i don't want to be mad at you i
don't like being mad at people who does
yeah
yeah and i mean obviously i would love
i want to just like
i feel like there's always a time where
it's like you need to be positive and
you need to be happy and there's
definitely times and a place to have to
choose happiness because sometimes that
is really a choice
but also to allow yourself to like feel
sadness and to allow yourself to feel
angry and the negative emotions because
if you run away from that
it's you have to feel it eventually you
know i know how special is it for you as
an artist to um be able to process those
feelings put it into a song and then
eventually perform this live to a
audience of people who know the words
that are saying back to you can also
feel what you're feeling like that's
gonna feel incredible oh my gosh it's it
is absolutely amazing and it's like one
of those things where it's not i'm not
happy that people had to have negative
experiences or negative like
relationships to be able to relate to
abc but i'm glad that we can all talk
about
our experiences and what it's like after
having those negative experiences and
having those negative relationships
coming and be like you know what i was
treated poorly
i was treated bad and like i'm mad about
that and i get to be mad about that
right
gosh and you're so young and processing
all this in in more mature ways than
even i could imagine you know what i
mean it's in there than the lyrics i
love it i'm curious though gail are do
you
i'm curious like how do you feel like
your success as an artist and a
songwriter is going to impact your
dating life like do you think guys are
going to meet you and be like oh i don't
want i don't want to be in a song i
don't want to be a song
oh man i don't know first of all i'm
trying to avoid musicians
we can am i doing a great job absolutely
not i'm trying though everything's gonna
love a
rockstar you know
i know
this is once they have a guitar and then
they oh it's game over it's game over
uh you know but um i feel like yeah
probably maybe somebody's gonna be
worried that i might write a song about
them but also like before
abc or anybody like anybody i was with
that was a songwriter even wasn't a
songwriter like they would still have
that same worry and i'm like just
exactly just don't cross her gentlemen
okay just don't cross her you know what
though like i feel like people love to
have like a love song written about them
or a breakup song written about you
until you until you piss the songwriter
off and oh all of a sudden it isn't so
fun to play
[Music]
what do you want to tell your fans who
are anxiously awaiting your debut ep
what do you want them to know about what
were what they have in store
oh sometimes i can act out of loneliness
and like other
emotions of mine can control the
decisions i make that aren't always the
most
healthiest things and
for me i found being aware of my
decisions that i've made and being aware
of
what emotion made me want to make those
decisions and talking about it openly
and always not seeing myself as the good
guy and like acknowledging the mistakes
i've made and the decisions i make has
been a way of me processing
my negative behaviors that can like
affect my life and my positive behaviors
and so
you know this project is really a look
on my human experience so i'm just very
excited to tell my story and also like
help
other people to tell theirs at the same
time
[Music]
you